hi there today we're looking at Impala
scalable distributed deep RL with
importance waited actor Lerner
architectures by law say SP halt
Hubert Sawyer Remy Munoz at AU so this
paper deals with a new architecture for
deep reinforcement learning specifically
distributed deep reinforcement learning
so that means settings where you go
beyond one single machine or beyond one
single accelerator like a GPU so I want
to introduce this by showing you this
task here this is called the deep mind
lab and the deep mind lab is a kind of a
3d environment as you can see or these
are screenshots where there are very
different goals but some of this as you
can see are kind of labyrinth style
things where you have to collect apples
sum or platformers where you I guess
have to jump around and so on find
objects so the deep man introduced this
as kind of a as an reinforcement
learning environment and what you can do
the agent as you can see here has a
camera it perceives pixels and it can
get rewards for performing actions the
actions it can perform is it can you
know walk back and forth it can jump
picking Crouch it can rotate so it this
is kind of a limited set of actions that
I can do but it can move around in this
3d world and it needs to achieve some
goals right so that that usually this is
kind of a good setting for reinforcement
learning and this paper doesn't doesn't
do a whole lot of new things in terms of
reinforcement learning but it does a lot
of things to kind of make it work in a
distributed setting so usually what you
would like to do is something like a to
see a to see is advantage actor critical
learning and it's it's a very successful
algorithm in reinforcement learning we
won't go into this much here but basic
elements of it is you
what you have are two things you have a
policy and usually this is called PI
sorry about that
usually this is called PI a policy that
you input your current state so your
current observation at time T and you
want to score an action right action aim
now you might have maybe as we saw
before you can walk left walk right and
so on so you might have 10 actions or so
so in here you would put action 1 or
action 2 or action 3 and for this you
would get probability distributions over
each action so maybe in this particular
state so each time with the same state
so you would get a distribution
something like this right so here you
should probably go with action 3 that's
your policy function policy function PI
tells you in this particular state which
action should you take how often kind of
gives you a distribution the second
thing you want is a what's called a
value function so the value function V
capital V usually you input your state
and it will output it will output what
the value is of that state and that's
usually termed canvas as a lowercase V
the value of the state is given if
you're in a maze right I'm gonna draw a
maze from the top here right and you
can't reach there like here so here is
the goal and let's say you are oops
you're right here the green right and
you have a choice of going forward to
the right or to the left now the this
would be this would be your policy here
your policy you would ask your policy
and a1 would maybe be go forward they to
go to the left
a3 to the right so your policy would
decide what to do your value function
ever would decide in each of the state
so where you are plus where you could go
here here here so basically for each
state in the system it would give you a
value in particular in this case it
would probably give you a very very high
value here like yeah this is a good
point because you're very close to the
goal right here
this is probably not so good a point and
this is a very bad point because you
you're going to corner you actually
moving farther away from the goal so if
your value function is trained well then
you can you can use that also to assess
your situation so the value function for
each state yes it will give you a
numerical value of how good that state
is in terms of reaching your goal and
the a2c algorithm now deals with the
interplay of these the 8uc uses actually
both of these in an interplay so it will
use one to teach the other one right and
this interplay between those gives mix
for a very successful reinforcement
learning algorithm now the way a to see
does it is as you can see here what it
does is it has two there are two
variants here stick the synched step and
synched trajectories but in essence it
has to run these episodes and these here
are steps in the episodes and let's say
in episode as four steps before it can
do the learning part and the learning
part is here the orange thing once it
has done a step of learning it has to
run episodes again and then it has can
do learning again and that's because of
a limitation of this which is called on
policy learning so on an on policy
learning you always want to have your
update step which is the orange part to
be fed with data so the this all of
these of these steps here go into this
update steps and it's necessary that the
steps that you make the updates from
are computed with kind of the most
current version of the of the agent
right so that the agent will go into the
world make some steps using its neural
network maybe I should explain so that
the agent right is this box and the
agent has this policy right and with
this policy as we saw it will go and it
will interact with the world right
outside of itself and it will kind of
the world will give back observations
and it will then interact again so you
can move a step forward right first
first thing is moves a step step forward
and then the world gives it back a aha
you are now no longer here you've moved
here right and then it's gone I want to
move to the left and the world says okay
so you're no longer here you've moved
one to the left and this on the right
here are the observations and there's on
the left here are the actions and for
the a to see is kind of necessary that
we always have a current version of the
policy generating these steps in order
to be able to learn from them and then
the next steps also need to be kind of
current until we learn now there have
been attempts to decentralize this and
is exactly what Impala does so Impala
splits this into multiple workers you
can think of this as different machines
so there is a split here and these are
called
actors and this is called a learner now
the actors they will go ahead and they
will run episodes on their own right
occasionally or they will run episodes
and they will communicate those episodes
to the learner and the learner will
continuously hear learn so these orange
steps can be made in much more quick
success succession and don't have to be
like synchronized as in the A to C here
is another way of seeing this over here
and we'll just concentrate on this on
this left thing here so there is a
learner
and there are actors and every now and
then the actor sinks its model from the
learner these are different machines so
this can happen over the network every
now and then the actor gets like an
update of the newest policy Network and
then the actor will just go ahead and
run episodes using that policy right
episode episode episode episode step
steps without interfering with anything
else and then once it has run an episode
or multiple it will communicate this
back to the learner and if all the
actors do this all right
the learner gets a whole bunch of these
episodes and then can learn from all of
them simultaneously and it can do so in
kind of with in in kind of very fast
succession as you see here so the work
is split of course you run into a
problem namely as we saw in the A to Z
algorithm this type of reinforcement
learning requires basically that you
always run the episode with the current
model and that's not the case here right
the actor may sink the parameters may
sink the parameters once in a while but
then it will run these episodes and when
it runs these episodes here it has no
idea or it the learner in the meantime
has continually been updating the model
while the actor kind of has an old model
so these episodes here are run with an
old model so the learner if it tries to
learn from this must kind of correct for
this fact and the big kind of
theoretical contribution of this paper
is how to correct for the fact that the
data you learn from comes from an
outdated policy model and this is what's
called V trace correction so without
going too much into the into the the
details here V trace correction
happens as as fall it happens as follows
so what you define or what's called V
trace targets and these V trace targets
are basically the targets that you train
your value function towards right so the
the the value function as we discussed
before that is a that is the thing that
tells you how good each state is and the
targets you train this towards and
you're also by the way using this we've
retrace corrections in policy updates
but these are defined as follows so the
V trace target for step s is the value
function at step s plus this correction
thing and the the correction thing
basically
well I've I want to break this down some
more so the the V at current s is your
value function plus and this is a sum
over all future steps over and this is a
discount factor and this is kind of a
delta from one step to the next so
you're in an episode and you've made
some steps right and let's say we are
here all right this is s and so your
your little V s will be whatever your
value function says of s plus kind of a
correction for each step that you make
go into the future like this and the
main part of these is is this here which
is basically the reward at the step plus
the difference of the value functions of
the steps after it and what V trace
introduces now is this bit here and
these CI again are
computed as such so of this kind of is
very nested so there's a there's a big
multiplication here it's a very nested
thing but in the very very very core of
it you can see the following these V
trace Corrections are a ratio between pi
and mu and pi is the policy of the
learner that is the current policy and
mu is the policy that has been used to
generate the to generate the episode and
this is truncated by a minimum and
usually the C bar is one so let's
consider what happens here what happens
is let's say that mu is higher than pi
for a given pair of AIX I what does it
mean it means that in the past you run
an episode you come you are in this maze
right such to them and you're here right
now the and the goal let's say the goal
is down here and the action is going
over here that that's the action that
you're considering here now your mu
which is your old policy that the actor
has synced at some point M you might say
this is very good
right because in your moves you towards
the goal that more but then your your PI
the learner has been learning since the
8 since the agent the actor has
synchronized the way it's the learner
has been learning and the learner might
know wait wait since you have decided
this I have actually learned that this
might not be such a good move because
you know there's a wall here and I'd
rather go down here and go and then over
here so what it will do it will
since pi is low and mu is higher it will
down way this action this is how you
correct for the fact that there are old
weights by basically down weighing
wherever the old policy thought of an
action as being worth more than the new
policy does and this is how you make up
for the fact that the new policy you
assume it knows better because it has
learned more and thereby you you give
lower weight to the data points where
the the policies have diverged a lot so
that's at the core of it
and you can think of in terms of here
you can think of it as maybe here at
this step you're at a point where the
old policy that the actor has has
updated itself to says we should do
action one right but the new policy that
the learner has in the meantime has
learned more says how we should do
action 2 and if this is the case then
this whole rest of the episode is down
wait because it is no longer current
knowledge right and this is not just
kind of a heuristic that they actually
do prove that this this this comes with
some guarantees especially reduces to
kind of the classic reinforcement
algorithms if you assume that mu is
always PI so that current policy is the
old policy and therefore you're in the
old setting all right so this was a bit
of a lengthy explanation of the math
behind it and at the end what you do is
following you train your value function
using this update and you can see here
it's simply the gradient of the value
function scaled by the thing that
contains this V trace target right you
then you update your policy in this
direction and this is the classic
reinforcement learning reinforced style
policy update where
here we have the gradient of the of the
policy and here you have the weighing by
the reward and specifically here it is
the reward Plus this V trace target and
this thing here is a bias correction or
a by introducing sorry variance reducing
bias that was terrible
the final form is what's called an
entropy penalty where you want to push
the entropy of your policy up such that
the agent kind of is biased towards
exploring more than exploiting if you
know of the classic exploration
exploitation dilemma so that's that's
what you do compute these V trace
targets update your value and policy
according to these equations and there
you go so what do what does Impala do
specifically in this deep mind lab if
two architectures first of all they have
this leftist small architecture second
they have this large architecture and
they just kind of try it out on this and
they measure how many frames per second
they can get in and you see here
compared to on single machine compared
to a three-c they bring in a lot more
frames per second this is just on a
single machine but then on distributed
setting the scale-up also is very
significant that they reach that's it
because they don't have to wait for
other things they can just go ahead
everything runs at full speed basically
and everything runs in parallel and the
fact that it that some of the
information is old is corrected by V
trace and the last thing I want to show
is the wall clock time I think this is
the important plot in this deep mind lab
on overall the tasks the wall clock time
compared to the score you can see a
three-c while it does you know
increase over time the Impala variants
appear increase in much much faster wall
clock time so that's the that's the
paper they have a lot of proofs in the
appendix which I'm not gonna go over if
you want to give it a try then it is it
is not called empower on github it is
called I think scalable agent so on
github it is called scalable agent
I think but you'll find it if you if you
search for Impala github or something
like this yeah other than that thanks
for listening and see you next time